texas governor greg abbott meantime
issuing an executive order restricting
the
transport of migrants who pose a risk of
carrying covet into texas communities
abbott is slamming the biden
administration for allowing coveted
positive migrants
to move around freely while hitting
americans with new rules
the bad administration cares more about
people who are not residents of america
than he does of the residents of america
because
uh he has one standard trying to mask up
and vaccinate
our fellow americans but by allowing
free pass
into the united states of people with a
high probability of covet and then
spreading that covet of in our
communities
as has been shown in the rio grande
valley so
what the bio administration is doing is
deadly it's dangerous and it must be
stopped
ken paxton texas attorney general joins
us now um thank you so much for
talking to us uh this morning there are
very large groups i mean back to back
845 migrants to be exact and counted in
just a 24-hour period
in rio grande valley um maybe you could
explain to our viewers just how serious
the situation is at the border with
these coveted cases as they continue to
pour in
so we've never seen this type of
migration into our state
and obviously with cove exposure we
that's that could potentially be deadly
for our citizens and so it's
hard to understand why the biden
administration so
focused on you know stopping the spread
of cobid with masks and mandates and
vaccinations
and yet they've opened our border up and
they've invited people to come and
they're telling people it's it's
basically okay to come
and here we are we've got the spread of
covet going on
at a greater rate than we did just a few
months ago and so it's really
irresponsible and
and dangerous for the body
administration to continue this practice
let's talk about governor greg abbott's
executive order is is called ga37 he
issued it just yesterday
it's going to restrict ground uh
transportation of migrants who pose a
risk
of possibly carrying coronavirus into
these texas communities which is of
course incredibly unfair
how severe of a punishment will there be
to those who don't abide by this rule
and how effective of a deterrent do you
believe this to be
you know i i applaud the governor for
doing he's doing everything he can
knowing that the biden administration is
working against us but what
that allows the local uh law enforcement
to do is basically
stop people that they are suspicious
have come across in violation of
of state and federal law and who might
have covet and basically send them back
to the border so it's no great
punishment unless we catch them
doing something else illegal they're
just being sent back to the border and
pushed through the point of entry to
make sure that they don't stay in our
state
and expose people potentially to more
code what makes this so much worse is
that you know
those that are detained are released so
i don't understand what the point is
then of detaining in the first place
uh republicans torching the biden
administration there's a report out
that states that 50 000 migrants have
been released without court dates
and they're literally just disappearing
into thin air into the u.s
into these texas communities into other
communities outside of texas
with only 13 of them appearing uh to the
ice officials that they're supposed to
meet
do you do you agree with that assessment
oh absolutely we've taken
an amazing step back this is what was
happening during the obama
administration
the way the asylum process worked people
came in they were released
they knew that they didn't have a
hearing for years and they never showed
up again
and everybody knew that you know
basically you come in you just claim
asylum whether you deserve it or not and
only a small percentage actually
qualify for it so now we're back to that
same policy they don't have to stay in
mexico
they disappear into the country and now
yeah with the exposure but that's going
all over the country we have no idea
where these people are going
yeah the tweets that were just up on the
wall if we can put them back to show you
how
outraged gop lawmakers are democratic
lawmakers should be equally outraged
calling it utterly lawless completely
asinine and shameful
senator bill haggerty calling it
predictable
you believe this is predictable this is
a predictable crisis
oh absolutely we knew from the obama
administration what didn't work and then
trump had to deal with this for four
years
and instituting certain policies like
the code restrictions and
making sure that criminals were not
released out of prison back into our
state into our country
and making sure that they had to stay in
mexico before they went through their
asylum process all of these things
worked including building a wall
and yet all of them have been pushed
aside
knowing exactly what was going to happen
which is we are back to pre-trump period
numbers and even worse and so we knew
this was going to have this was
predictable the binding administration
wants this to happen and they want it to
happen knowing that the spread of cohen
will be greater
yeah well the white house is still um
blaming the trump administration you
just touched on that
this has been an issue obviously since
the biden administration
behind the border crisis it's really a
border chaos
as it releases its plan to deal with the
root causes now
this coming just nearly two months after
vice president harris's visit to
guatemala
five months into her role at this point
as the person on the crisis
she was supposed to find the root of the
cause when she visited guatemala
two months ago so the plan includes
addressing economic inequality combating
corruption
tackling domestic violence among other
issues what would you say about this
plan the white house is finally putting
forward
well i don't think it's going to work i
mean it's going to take years to figure
out what the root cause is we know what
the root cause is the biden
administration has changed all the rules
to rules that didn't work before and so
to blame the trump administration you
know they keep talking about science as
it relates to
covid why don't they just look at the
numbers the numbers speak for themselves
go back a year ago and look at the
numbers on uh how many immigrants we had
coming in and what was going on with
with stopping people at the board and
look at the numbers now they're
dramatically different there's no doubt
that the change in policy
has made things multiple multiple times
worse
and the biden administration continues
to blame the trump administration when
the problems were there before the trump
administration which is a lesson that
should be learned by all politicians
the blame game just does not work get
the job done uh all right ken paxton
thank you very much for talking to us
today